how are you guys good fantastic show on
Netflix question one will you binge your
own show we already have the binge it
because they we got like like a couple
episodes at a time yes but like when I
we would be given like a chunk I would
watch the chunk and then just so angry
we were gonna get 8 9 and then 10 yeah
well cuz I wonder about that because is
there a part of being with something
like this that's so good but when you're
in it like you don't get to really watch
it as a fan like there's a great show on
Netflix right now that you guys can't
watch as fans of that show yeah and a
dream in terms of an ensemble because
then I get to see so much other stuff
that I'm not in right blown away and by
like their performances and it's so fun
I think that's what's amazing about the
show is because of the ensemble element
we we do go to that you know I when I
was watching it I was still getting the
kind of shock moments that I knew were
happening as I'd read the script yeah I
was like oh and then you read it once
and then you kind of have to focus in on
like your scenes and your storyline and
so there'd be so many things that I had
completely forgotten about and like I
was jumping out of my own skin it's
moments just like get like getting
myself like Alison getting myself with
with Gerard Way My Chemical Romance did
you guys know this did you guys know the
material ahead of time before going into
this at all I think all of us didn't
weren't really for me no no before
starting before he came into his you
know and then once the project came to
us through breakdowns and stuff from
from our various teams and agents and
stuff we all obviously googled it and
got the comics and I always say this
that there was something about it when I
saw the image that just intrigued me
before I even read the script before I
even looked at the comics or something
about the image of these characters all
next to each other and thought how does
this work as some kind of superhero team
you know and from the off it really
intrigued me I was interested from just
from that with this the pacing is
fantastic there's the the reveal is
happens gradual
which is which is great but also you see
these characters in every single
character the first time you see them
you realize they're all going through
some stuff there's some pain there's
some family secrets there's stuff in the
closets what was it like to sort of go
in with a character like that where you
knew that there was that much to work
with they were that deep even for a
superhero show
I mean first and foremost that's what
attracted all of us do this show is how
complex these characters are and reading
the comics you it doesn't really dive
into the psyche of each of them and like
they're really you it's kind of like
more broad strokes you know being able
to you know dive into you know Allison's
going through a divorce she's fighting
for has actually lost custody of her
daughter and she's kind of in a weird
place with using her powers and she's
trying to find a sisterhood with her
sister that she never really had I think
there's so much there and that that
instantly just drew me to to the show
and the role Ellen you've been in this
world before the ensemble's superhero
crew did you how did you want to get
back into this did you sort of have that
craving to kind of get back into this
world did you miss it no I
it wasn't really that I mean to be
honest it's that I I'd been wanting to
do TV I'd been like wanting to
experience living with a character for
so long and then I got so lucky that
steve blackman you know was interested
in me being a part of this and it's
funny because like on paper I get it
like I see the similarities but it feels
incredibly different
it's a incredibly different it
approaches the genre an incredibly
different way and first and foremost I
was drawn to what the core of this story
is and in particular this character
which is one of my favorite I've ever
gotten to play yeah
Faramir favorite mary j blige song and
also I forget the name of it please sing
it why it's George Michael one the only
the George Michael I really love the one
with George Michael
this guy ideally a karaoke screen with
hilarious because I clearly don't know
I've seen as dancing in the show oh yeah
yeah she does an unbelievable cover in
our show yeah and I think I it's kind of
talking some of her own charts from yeah
that's great yeah and I just how amazing
was it to have her around the dance
floor the other night at the premiere
like she's just a hoot she's she's so
sweet she's so caring
she's so she wants so desperately to do
right by everyone that has helped her
get to where she is and what she's doing
right and and to be involved with the
cast and and and I just my passion for
it she's so passionate about what she's
doing totally and I think she just she
wanted you know she did want to let
anybody down
yeah it's a new chapter for her yes
stuff and she's she's so eager to just
get it right you know so sure her
eagerness to learn you know on set you
know just just being on set and how to
you know day to day she's just brilliant
yeah she's like a sponge endo before I
uh before I go speaking you're fans of
shows do you have into the final season
of Game of Thrones do you have anybody
who you hope gets the throne oh I want
someone to get it okay
because you know keep it in the blood to
keep the whaler family right it starts
fights these conversations get you
involved you know because it's like
since being is that show people
genuinely care about your opinion about
it and I'm sort of like well I I'm
really not that first you know I don't
really mind we go I am dead - so
and this shows like this you know that
this puts you into you know this world
would be with these fans these sort of
comic fans you could spend the rest of
your lives going from convention to
convention and probably live a happy
life doing them
the fans are what makes this genre so
have you had what is your interaction
been so far with with Brazil and that
was unbelievable this was my
introduction jaibo them have kind of
been in this comic-con world for a
little bit and I I just had didn't know
what to expect I have no expectations
and it was unbelievable the amount of
like love and excitement and just how
should passion yeah it's just so cool
it's it's like truly truly like an honor
to like be a part of like if I dare say
a family of like yeah to be just in that
environment these these guys that they
go to these Comic Cons they're the ones
that really make your show a hit or not
because if they get passionate about it
they're the ones that scream from the
rooftops yeah and and keeping those fans
of speakers because you know the ones
who read the conference they're the ones
that we really want to please because
they're the ones that made the comic
what it is now like same thing they
though those friends are the ones that
are sort of beating heart of the comic
so we want to please them and who has
the best dance moves that was when my
favorite scenes I've seen in a
television show in years
whose moves were the best David David is
very good surprised because we didn't I
didn't see that coming no I mean it was
anyone we saw the first episode on
because I did I was in there for his
dance moves and I was like oh my god he
can make property see pop when I say I'm
like you've done that before
you've done that same dance before alone
in your room another amazing dance
coming later in the season and the
phenomenal choreographer Emma partner
yeah
yeah thank you so much guys I wrote you
guys right on thank you yeah really
crazy thanks so much
you